[موسيقى]
جزاء الغيم تنهمر الحروف
لها نغم يحس به الشغوف
يرى فيها غصونا باسقات
على اطرافها تدنو القطوف
فان لبثت مقاليد المعاني مسطره تنوء بها
الرفوف
فتحنا في صميم العلم بابابا فقال الدهر قد
جاز الوقوف
كفى قلم الخطاط مجدا ورفعه مدى الدهر ان
الله اقسم بالقلم السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
السفير هو الرسول يقال سافرت بين القوم
اذا كنت بينهم رسولا فانا اسفر سفاره وهم
السفراء يقول الشاعر ومشعله ترى السفراء
فيها كان وجوههم عصب مضاجوا روي ان يعقوب
انه قال قد لوحتهم الحرب وغيرتهم فكان
وجوههم عصب قد لوحته النار
الحديث عن السفير الوزير ايضا
له نصيب من
تاصيل الكلمات الوزير من الفعل وزره
يقول الله تعالى ولا تزر وازره وزراء اخرى
من هذا الوزر وهذه الوزيره جاءت تسميه
الوزير والوزاره
فعندما يستوزر الوزير يستوزره الحاكم فهو
يقول له انني احملك وزر هذه الدائره او
هذه الوزاره التي استوزرتك فيها فمن الوزر
جاء التسميه الوزير الوالي مثلا الوالي هو
الذي يلي امر الناس ويطلع بهم فهي من
الفعل ولي
الملك من الملك والامير من الامر فالامير
هو الذي يامر ويطاع
[موسيقى]
قيل لاعرابي ممن انت قال من قوم اذا احبوا
ماتوا فقالت جاريه سمعته عذري رب الكعبه
ومعنى قولها عذري اي انه من بني عذره وبنو
عذره تشتهر بالحب العذري الذي نسب اليهم
وهو الغزل العفيف وقد يعشق الاعرابي عندهم
ويكتم ذلك في نفسه خوفا على محبوبته فيموت
كمدا وحزنا على محبوبته اذا تزوجت من غيره
او يموت من كتمان حبها في صدره
لقد كتمت الهوى حتى تهيمني لا استطيع لهذا
الحب كتمانا
روي ان رجلا انشد ابا عثمان المازني شعرا
رديئا ثم قال كيف تراه يا ابا عثمان قال
ابو عثمان اراك قد عملت عملا عظيما باخراج
هذا من جوفك لانك لو تركته لاورثك السلم
[موسيقى]
ذكر صاحب العقد الفريد ان ابا يعقوب
الخريمي سمع منصور بن عمار يقول في دعائه
اللهم اغفر لاعظمنا ذنبا واقسانا قلبا
واقربنا بالخطيئه عهدا واشدنا على الدنيا
حرصا فقال له امراه طالق ان كنت دعوت الا
لابليس يعني بالعاميه علي الطلاق انك تدعو
لابليس شخصيا طبعا تكثر في هذه الايام
الايمان بالطلاق فتجد انه علي الطلاق انت
تتعشى عندي بكره وعليه الطلاق انك تاخذ
مني واخذ منك وهذا فيبدو انها يعني من
قديم والامر على هذه الحال ولا حول ولا
قوه الا بالله
قيل لمعاويه من اسود الناس قال اسخاهم
نفسا حين يسال واحسنهم في المجالس خلقا
واحلمهم حين يستجهل
وقال بعض الحكماء الحر من اعتقته المحاسن
والعبد من استعبدته المقابح
وقال سعيد ابن المسيب لا خير في مال رجل
لا يصلح به عرضه ويصل به رحمه ويستغني به
عن الاثام
وقال محدثكم لا يتواضع الا من وقر في نفسه
علو قدره وثبات مكانته
[موسيقى]
يقولون فلان تاجر فاصبح خسرانا وهذا خطا
الصواب اصبح خاسرا يقول تعالى ومن يتخذ
الشيطان وليا من دون الله فقد خسر خسرانا
مبينا
ويقولون الدهن المستخرج من الحيوان مثلا
له منافع ويكسرون الدال في كلمه دهن
والصواب الدهن بضم الدال يقول تعالى وشجره
تخرج من طور سيناء تنبت بالدهن وصبغا
للاكلين
يقولون نام الجنود على فراشهم والصواب ان
نقول ناموا على فرشهم او افرشتهم لان
الفراش مفرد يقول تعالى
متكئين على فرش بطائنها من استبرق وجنى
الجنتين دان
[موسيقى]
هذه بدائل عربيه لكلمات اعجميه اشتهرت على
السنه الناس عامتها وخاصتها
الاتوبيس بديله العربي الحافله
والموتوسيكل بديله العربي الدراجه واللانش
بديله العربي الزورق والونش هو الرافعه
والشاسيه بديلها العربي الهيكل والاستبن
او الاسبير بديله العربي الاحتياط
[موسيقى]
يقول المثل فلان له خلق كاخلاق البغال فما
هي اخلاق البغال اعزكم الله
اخلاق البغال يضرب به المثل لمن يكثر
التلون يقول الجاحظ لما كان البغل من
الخلق المركب والطبائع المؤلفه والاخلاق
المختلفه تلون في اخلاقه الكثيره العيوب
المتولده عن مزاجه وشر الطباع ما تجاذبته
الاعراق المتضاده والاخلاق المتفاوته
والعناصر المتباعده وقال في موضع اخر
البغل كثير التلون وبه يضرب المثل قال
البحتري يهجو قوما لهم حلل حسنه فهن مبيض
واخلاق سمجنه فهن سود واخلاق البغال فكل
يوم يعن لبعضهم خلق جديد
[موسيقى]
ضيفنا في هذا الجزء من الحلقه الخطاط
الاستاذ نضال ابراهيم اغا يا مرحبا يا
اهلا ومرحبا حياك الله
تاريخ الخط عندما ننظر الى نسخه قديمه من
نسخ القران الكريم نفترض مثلا مصحف عثمان
نجد انه مكتوب بحرف يكاد يكون صعبا على
اهل هذا اليوم قراءته بعد ذلك بدانا نرى
فن الخط خطوط واضحه جليه فمتى بدا الخط
كفن
بدايه استاذ محمد الخط العربي كان الغايه
منه فقط التدوين
الكتابه حفظ اشعار العرب وعلومهم
في العصر العباسي نقول يعني ان ابن مقلى
هو اول من انتقل بالخط العربي من الناحيه
الوظيفيه الى الناحيه الفنيه بالنقل
الوزير نعم الوزير المغلق نعم ومن بعده
ابن بواب وياقوت المستعصمي يعني هنا الخط
بدا ياخذ منحا فنيا صرفا هل هذا يعني
بعوامل ازدهار مئه بالمئه الدوله نعم صحيح
طيب
تعدد انواع الخط
هل لها اصل يعني كيف نشات هذه الخطوط مثلا
هل كان هناك خط واحد ثم تفرعت منه هذه
الخطوط نعم هذه يعني اشهر الاقوال في هذا
الامر كان يعرف الخط بقلم الطمار بدايه
الطمار نعم وكان قلما كما يقال لكن كبيرا
بالحجم جاء خطاطون اختصروه بثلثي
قلم الطمار فسمي بقلم الثلثين
جاء من بعدهم ايضا اختصروه ايضا الى قلم
الثلث الذي هو خط الثلث المعروف حاليا
عندنا
الثلث هو ثلث الطمار نعم اصله طمار
والنسخ هو ما كانوا ينسخون به صحيح صحيح
لسهولته سهوته ووضوحه ولانه يقبل الحركات
ليست كل خطوط تقبل الحركات
خط الرقعه مثلا لا يقبل الحركه اما النسخ
يقبل الحركات بشكل كامل لماذا يسمى نفس
تعليق
الفارسي يسمى يقال ان الحركات المشتركه
بين خط النسخ والتعليق من ناحيه تحريف
القلم فيسمى بهذا الاسم هذه طبعا نظريات
وهو يعني مختص بفارس نعم هو سمي بالفارسي
لكثره كتابته في بلاد فارس يعني اليوم
نسمع قصيده مثلا فيها بيت مكسور نحكم عليه
من خلال الميزان العروضي او نسمع لحن
النشازن فنعرف انه نشاز لكن كيف تعرفون
النشاز في الخط ما هي المعايير هناك امران
مهمان في الحرف مقاييس الحرف وشخصيه الحرف
هذان امران يجب ان يجتمع حتى يكتمل شكل
الحرب مقاييس بمعنى ماذا مقاييس النقاط
الحروف تقاس في النقاط فحرف الالف مثلا في
خط الرقعه قياسه ثلاث نقاط اذا كان اربع
نقاط اصبح شكله الالف الالف في الرقعه
ثلاثه نقاط والالف في خط اخر قديم النسخ
مثلا خمس نقاط نعم في الثلوج سبع نقاط
فهذا امر وشخصيه شخصيه الحرف يعني انا
اداء الحرف ربما اكتب حرفا صحيحا المقاييس
لكن هناك ضعف في ادائه ايضا امر يعني
يساعد في ان يكون الخط جيدا او لا هناك
جهات تمنح شهاده لمن يجيد الخط بشكل جيد
للاسف قليل جدا في بلادنا
معظمه يعني تحصيل ذاتي ان اساتذه كما انا
ان اخذت اخذت اجازه من استاذي من استاذك
استاذ عدنان الشيخ عثمان الاستاذ عدنان
الشيخ
اعطاك شهاده بعد ملازمته ثلاثه عشره عاما
ما شاء الله
13 عاما وانت ملازم لهم وبعد ذلك اجازه
نعم في الخط العربي اجازه كيف بخط دون اخر
ام بخطوط مختلفه نعم
كما يعني
ان الذين يقراون القران يجازون احيانا
بروايه دون اخت خطر لي ربما انتم تجازون
احيانا هناك بعض اجازات شكلها بهذا الشكل
نعم تكون بهذا الشكل لاني ايضا يعني تعرفت
الى خطاطين
وجدتهم مثلا عاكفين على خط واحد دون غيره
يقولون لا انا يعني ابدع مثلا في الفارسي
ولا اجيد غيرها او لا اريد ان يعني
هذه فكره وفكره عند الخطاطين العرب الوارد
اكثر ان يتقنوا معظم الخطوط في يوم من
الايام سالت الاستاذ عارف الحجاوي قلت له
يعني هو عمل خطاطا فتره طويله ويحب الخط
فقلت له يعني ما هي اهم صفه يجب ان يتحلى
بها الخطاط من اجل ان يكون مبدعا فقال لي
هما امران اولا الاعصاب بتكون مشدوده
ثانيا ان يكون عند القدره على التكرار
بحيث اذا وقع لك توقيعا مثلا يستطيع ان
يقلد هذا التوقيع ولو الف مره دون ان يغير
دون ان يحيد عنه والله اضيفوا لهذين
الامرين الصبر الصبر الصبر ثم الصبر ثم
الصبر تتمرن يوميا على الخط
لو مر عليك اسبوع مثلا وحاله دون التمرين
امر ما تفقد شيئا من المعاكيض كما الصوت
كما الرياضه لا بد من التمرين ما رايك ان
نقوم معا لنستعرض بعضا من لوحاتك واتحدث
عنها
[موسيقى]
ان الله اصطفى ادم ونوحا وال ابراهيم وال
عمران على العالمين هذا الثلث الثلث
الجليل الجلي من الوضوح من الوضوح كلغه
ولكن في كمصطلح خطي الجليل والمتراكب الذي
يكتب بقصبه تبلغ سمكتها نصف سمتر فما فوق
5 ملم فما فوق هذه الكتابه يعني طريقه ما
يشبه الخط المقوس والدائره مثلا هل لها
تسميه خاصه ام انها مجرد يعني زخرفه ان
تكون هكذا استاذ محمد كما ان في اللغه
محسنات بديعيه فان في الخط هذه المحسنات
جميل فنجد هنا الدائره في الوسط والشكل
المقوس تحتها ونلاحظ كاس الحاء المفرغ من
التشكيل داخله هنا ويقابله كاس العين
المفرغ ايضا تناظر يعني تناظر مئه بالمئه
والالف المقصوره الراجعه اتت في وسط
اللوحه يا سلام نعم هذا نوع من المحسنات
البديعيه في الخط نعم جميل نعم طيب هل
المحسنات مثل معروفه ام يعني هي ارتجاليه
كل حسب اجتهاده احسنت
وهناك من يعني يصنفها في هذه هنا محسن
بديعي اخر
للناس ولينذروا به وليعلموا ان ما هو اله
واحد وليتذكر اولو الالباب نعم هنا نلاحظ
المد في هذا يعلوه كاس الغين جميل يقابله
المد في به يعلوه كاس العالم نلاحظ هنا
هذه واو مجموعه يقابلها مجموعه في الوسط
الواو المرسله في السطر الاسفل هنا نلاحظ
الواوات الاربع المرسله يا سلام هذه اذا
نسميها واوا مجموعه تلك مرسل وهذه مرسله
يا سلام رائع جميل هذا ايضا ثلث مركب كلهم
ثلث كله كله اذا ننتقل الى هذه اللوحه هنا
هذه مركبه بشكل يعني صراحه يعني كان صعبا
علي ان اقراها لكني قراتها بعد ذلك
وان
تعفوا وتصفحوا وتغ
فان الله غفور رحيم
يعني دائما مثلا البدايه يجب ان تكون من
هذه الزاويه ام انه بامكانك مثلا ان تبدا
من هنا البدايه في في لوحات الخط العربي
تدفع لوجود اسم جلاله اللوحه
فان كان في اخر لوحه بدانا من الاسفل كي
ينتهي في الاعلى يا الله
تادبا مع الله سبحانه يا سلام نلاحظ هنا
توزيع الهندسي استاذ محمد هذا كاس العين
وفي الوسط كاس الحاء وهنا الغين
وفي الوسط هنا ايضا
فاذا كان لفظ الجلاله في بدايه الايه
بداتم من الاعلى يا سلام الله يهدي معلومه
لا تقدر بثمن جميله جدا
[موسيقى]
ان الكريم دائما اهل للمدح
وما احسن المدح حين يقع في اهله
للمكرومات البيض جئت مكملا والمكرمات تقدس
الاكمال تممت بالفعل الجميل قصيده والفعل
عندك يسبق الاقوالا يا ابن الذين تسلسلت
احسابهم بالعز اجيال النمت اجيالا السلام
عليكم
[موسيقى]